- I'm Ali, and this is my son, Rafael.
I am hoping to learn
American Sign Language
over the next 60 days.
Yay!
When Rafael was born, he
failed his newborn hearing
screening at the hospital.
At six weeks old, we
were given the diagnosis
that he has profound
unilateral hearing loss
in his right ear, which
means he is completely deaf
in his right ear, and
that means there's a lot
of question marks.
He does have normal
hearing in his left ear,
but I've talked to parents
all over the country
with children with
unilateral hearing loss,
and their experiences are vastly different
in terms of communication.
Some kids do totally fine
with just one working ear.
Some kids rely completely
on American Sign Language
as their form of
communication, and some lie
somewhere in between.
When we got that first
diagnosis from the audiologist,
the experience there was a little bit dry.
You know, she sort of
gave us the diagnosis
and then immediately tried to sell us
a certain brand of hearing aid.
She sorta presented it as
this is the only solution.
She sent us to an ENT and we didn't have
a great experience there either.
We felt sort of very lost after that.
We decided to get a second opinion,
so we went to Children's Hospital,
and we found an audiologist
who gave us the same diagnosis
but talked to us more
about different options.
We felt more listened to.
And the very next day, I got a phone call
from someone reaching out
to me, saying, you know,
we received your son's
diagnosis and we're gonna
put you in touch with a
group called ParentLinks,
which is a community
for parents of children
with hearing loss, so you can connect
with other parents who are
going through the same thing.
It's been incredible
to be enveloped by this
amazing community of parents and educators
and people who are advocates
for children with hearing loss.
That's one of the reasons
why I'm really interested
in learning ASL is just
to give him another tool,
another way of communicating with him.
I just wanna give him every
opportunity to succeed.
I think he's extraordinary.
At the very beginning, I started taking
some online ASL lessons, and
at first, it was very basic.
It was just sort of like words.
So after about a week
and a half of online,
I'm learning a lot of vocabulary words.
I was sick last week, so
I know that I was sick.
The hard part for me right now,
and the frustrating is like
putting it all together
and trying to create sentences,
because the grammar and
the sentence structure
is very, very different.
Every time I look at my
kid and I see that he knows
the sign for more.
More, you want more?
Or I think about how, yes,
it might be difficult,
but I wanna keep going and I wanna be able
to help him communicate more.
It was really hard learning online only,
because I didn't have anyone
to sort of like feedback with.
And then I actually started
working with an ASL tutor, Loni.
We just had our first
meeting and it was really
intimidating at first.
As soon as I saw her, I said,
"Hi, I'm Ali, nice to meet you."
You know, and she was
happy that I knew that.
But then, I just sort of forgot myself
and started talking to her.
I said, "We're gonna go
to Kate's desk right now
"and get some paperwork,"
and she had to remind me,
"I'm deaf," but she made
me feel at ease right away,
'cause she could tell
that I was very nervous.
I did a lot of writing things down today,
because I was a little
overwhelmed, overwhelmed.
I know that's okay, sort
of, at the beginning,
but I wanna be respectful of Loni
and not sort of have to write
everything down all the time.
There was really great,
because actually having
one-on-one time to go back and
forth and practice my signs
with an actual person
who knows the language,
it was just like a whole
'nother world of learning.
So I'm gonna quiz myself
on some of these flashcards
that Loni and I have been working on.
I will not look, but I'll show you.
So this sign is daughter.
(bell rings)
So I'm about halfway through.
One of the things I really
need to start working on now,
too, is to actually have conversation.
And that's where it gets
a little bit tricky,
because ASL is its own language.
There's two different things.
There's signed English, which is,
"Do you want a banana or an apple?"
But in ASL, that same
sentence would simply just be,
"Apple, banana, which?"
That's a really rudimentary example,
but a lot of things like
that are very tricky
to sort of get the grammar and moving
things around into sentences.
This is Loni.
She's my tutor for ASL.
It's important that I have a tutor
because part of the grammar
is your facial expressions,
so it really helps to have another person.
(bright music)
One of the first things
I learned how to say is,
"How do you say?"
So I was trying my hardest
to be able to communicate
only using sign.
It's been a little over 60
days since this whole endeavor
started, and I'm feeling
really good about my progress.
I feel like I'm finally starting
to like put sentences together.
I'm getting really excited to start
actually speaking in ASL.
(bright music)
And now that I've had
sort of a taste for it,
I'm really falling in
love with the language.
I feel like this is something
that's gonna bond us,
and it's going to make him understand
that sort of no matter what he needs,
he'll always be able
to communicate with me.
(bright music)
- Hey, Unsolved is on a new channel.
And now your part.
- [Both] Subscribe here.
- That was my part.